Roman, I'm going to ask a provocative
question, but I think it's an important
one. Do you think the religion of Islam
is compatible with the West?
>> No, it's not. And if you mean by the
West, the sort of secular liberal west,
it's certainly not. If the West believes
in freedom of religion and uh gender
equality and everything that the West,
you know, prizes, well, in Islam, it's
not. It's not that. There's a radical
interpretation. Honestly, it's not. Like
I told you, that's the observant
interpretation. Um, which is that, so
for example, um, you have to, okay, you
have to hate the non-Muslim.
Is that something that, you know, if
you're living in a liberal western
secular society, you really want a group
of people who are bound to feel that way
towards you? How's that going to work
out? Oh, I know how it works out. Just
look at the UK, right? Um, so there's
there are builtin teachings in Islam
inherently. Not a lot. I'm not saying
the whole religion. There's a lot of it
that that's actually neutral, maybe some
of it that's admirable, but there are
just enough that bring it at odds with
the things that the west actually
prizes. Okay. Um
the okay killing blasphemers or you know
attacking them. So in the west freedom
of expression and art and whatnot and
then what was his name? Van Gogh. that
guy gets killed, right? Because well, in
the Muslim world, everyone would agree
with that and they would pat him on the
back because that's what you do. So, the
religion itself has built-in sort of
mechanisms that does make it
antithetical to a lot of the things that
the West prizes.
>> And so, I guess the next question is
if it's if it's completely antithetical,
is it therefore an existential threat to
the West?
>> Yeah. again. But again, it gets murky
when you realize, so what are we talking
about? Islam, you know, I'm almost, it's
kind of like I'm anthropomorphizing it
as if Islam's a man. Islam is made up of
Muslims. And I already readily agree a
lot of Muslims are not real Muslims or
not observant Muslims or cultural
Muslims or secular Muslims. You have a
lot of that. I get that. And they uh,
you know, presumably can assimilate. I'm
sure a lot of them do. But the problem
is you have the the teachings exist and
though the teachings themselves are the
existential threat because there will be
people who do adhere to those teachings
and once they do they become the bad
guys. Okay, which which and nobody wants
to see it's funny every time I re I look
at Muslims attacking someone randomly
and in Europe for example and all of a
sudden it's dismissed as oh he had
mental problems, oh he had psychological
issues. No, he was actually I mean
that's how we see it, but no, he was
actually following a directive and
something that breeds a certain contempt
and hatred for precisely the kind of
person he attacked. Okay, so again, I'm
not trying to say that would be
scaremongering if I was sitting here to
tell you every single Muslim wants to
kill you and be No, they don't. I get
that. You know how many time you know
how many Muslims that you can look at
today and you might be like, well, is
this guy dangerous? And then tomorrow
that guy converts to Christianity. But
for 10 years and I've known them, this
guy has been conflicted and and for
those 10 years he was not even a Muslim
but and he was almost a Christian. So my
point is you don't know. There's a lot
of these people there's so much gray and
a lot of them are not a threat. A lot of
them are great people. Okay, but again
you know it's how do you differentiate
and how do you know and uh and this is
why you know it's it's nice and it's
good for the west to not discriminate.
Okay. But on the other hand, by not
discriminating or just being
intelligent, we're going back to the
analogy of, you know, 100 um you know,
candies and one even is poisonous and
you know it is and you so okay the 99
didn't cause the problem, but the one
will and that's why you continuously
have the attacks that you continue
having because in as much as you keep
taking these numbers, there's a
percentage that's going to come with the
violence and those things that are
antithetical to Western culture. So that
being the case, the UK is in the
situation it's in. If you were advising
the UK on this particular issue, what
policies would you put in place? What
advice would you give the government?
>> Yeah. Well, that's not that easy
because, you know, the the UK has really
dug itself deep already. It's one thing
to say, hey, we don't want to bring in
too many Muslims, okay, like these other
countries we were mentioning.
>> But when you already have what is it you
said 4 million?
>> Mhm. Um
you know it's uh well first of all
anyone who's illegal I would say has to
go immediately. I mean if you're there
illegally by no more coming in um I
would I don't know how if they do this
but I would really be monitoring uh
mosques and the Islamic kind of uh
programming and what Muslims are being
exposed to including on the internet
which I'm sure is not so easy. So, and
this is, you know, and it's and you at
one point you start wondering, is it
worth all this? Like, what does a
western nation get from having to live
constantly on its toes um just to be
able to live side by side with Muslims?
But I guess again, in this case, I get
it because they're already there, right?
Um but I would have no I would have no
compunction or sympathy for any sort of
radical preaching. I mean, I see in the
UK radical Muslims screaming, you know,
like actual Islamic jihadist stuff and
they don't get in trouble, but then when
a a British person fights back, they get
arrested. Okay, so this is what I'm
telling you. This is the real problem
right now. And you know, so when you
tell me you what advice I could give,
how about start off by um just being
objective and without this two-tier
system where you're actually oppressing
the natives and empowering those who are
actually, you know, pushing for this
sort of thing, the jihadist mentality.
>> Would you would you do more hardline
approaches? For instance, something like
banning halal, banning uh facial
coverings, banning burgers, et the
facial covering is there's that's a
security reason. In fact, in some in
Muslim countries, it's sometimes the
case women can't wear the hijab because
it's sometimes you get a terrorist.
>> Like I said, inbakistan, you can't wear
you can't wear full face cover.
>> Yeah. So that Yeah, for sure. There's no
problem with that. Um
and and you know, if there's a way to
stop the sort of de ghettoize them so
they they do possibly assimilate instead
of always kind of living closely net and
is like I said, a small ribbot or
Islamic fortification. Um it's not very
easy. I mean, I think and especially for
>> especially for the mentality that
prevails right now in the UK and its
leadership, like I said, they you're
asking me, let's say this is neutral.
You're asking me the measures they can
take. They're still here,
>> you know, where they're attacking their
own and you can't what country tells its
citizens you can't, you know, wave your
flag. I mean, you know, this is one of
the things that I often point out. If
you want to know how insane it is in
Europe, always look at by analogy other
non-western regions. And guess what? You
know, like I I I made this argument
recently, you know, I don't know if you
use the same ter terminology, but in
America, the ultraight is like the bad
guy. This is like the racist xenophobe,
you know, crazy patriot. And to me, the
ultraight is actually how everyone
outside the West thinks and acts. Okay?
They're all, if you go to any country,
non-western, which is subsaharan, Asian,
Latin American, what we call ultraright,
traditional, you like your country, you
like your flag, that's what they're
that's normative there. And the ones who
support it most are their own
governments. That's what they want you
to be like. It's very weird to go to a
nation like the UK where, oh, you're the
bad guy because you're waving your
nation's flag, but then these people are
coming in waving their flags, including
ISIS, and that's okay. I mean, so you
the UK's problems, man, they're just uh
kind of mindboggling. I don't even know
where to begin. It's just uh it's really
warped.
[music]
Heat.